since that day in 94 do you take things
as seriously is there an air of and I'm
at a loss for words but time freak sleep
is an inconvenience
I don't sleep so I I don't like I got
things I want to do because
you know it's interesting because when I
was preparing these notes I saw
something on Quora which is the social
media platform and someone posted a
question do you think people that have
higher energy levels have an unfair
advantage and for some reason I really
wanted to ask you this question it was
just like it wasn't the normal question
but I really felt the need to ask it to
you and we put it as one of the ones at
the bottom but it sounds like you have a
lot of energy whether it's through the
meditation and it renews you but have
you seen that in other people where
maybe their energy level is not as high
and so they don't get as many things
done and is that high energy level in
this necessary
you know the multitasking like that the
volume of the energy higher low is
important but what's more important is
it focused people with lower energy
levels get things done too because
they're focused toward higher the net
energy levels a lot of things right but
they're not focused a higher energy
without a plan without a vision without
a stress strategy is called frustration
lower high energy without focus is
frustration I may want it I see it over
there but how am I gonna get over there
if it's a mountain I think I need
climbing boots in a rope and stuff but I
just want to go over there no but dude
it's up but I want to go over there I
want to go over there
you